researcher alice was having a very long
day working at the scp foundation can
sound like a pretty exciting job to an
outsider the problem is when you deal
with something exciting every day of
your life it starts to become as mundane
as brushing your teeth or pouring your
morning bowl of breakfast cereal over
time everything loses its magic she had
the unenviable job of double checking
the anomalies in c-wing of site-77
glorified box ticking she trudged from
containment chamber to containment
chamber everything seeming to be in
order tick tick tick it was all euclid
and safe class anomalies anyway hardly
major containment risks but when she
reached the chamber for scp-2805
the security cameras normally used to
observe the anomaly were on the fritz
she'd need to go inside great when the
chamber doors opened she felt an
immediate chill her breath came out as
an icy fog in the distance she saw a jar
sitting on a podium the glass so frosted
over she couldn't quite make out what
was inside no sign of a containment
breach she ticked the box next to
scp-2805 on her clipboard and moved on
several hours later researcher ellis was
at home finally able to relax since she
started working at the foundation
dealing with deadly creatures and cursed
artifacts on a daily basis she'd long
for the simple comforts of childhood in
her down time that's why she decided to
spend her evening with a warm mug of hot
chocolate a bowl of ice cream and her
favorite animated disney movie mulan she
had just pressed play when she got a
phone call from an unknown number with a
frustrated groan she picked up the phone
and answered the voice on the other end
was a little gravelly but it sounded
kind his diction was old-fashioned a man
from a bygone era why hello there young
lady i hope this isn't a bad time he
said the name's walt want disney perhaps
you've seen some of my motion pictures i
was wondering if i could trouble you for
some help with a project of mine this
might have been some stupid prank call
maybe dr bride or dr clef was bored and
decided they wanted to mess with her the
fact that she was watching a disney
movie at the time was pure coincidence
after all they own half the movies out
there these days but that's when walt
carried on talking to her you see my
dear i'm a little short on time at the
moment i realize i
perhaps don't have the longevity that i
used to i won't get into the illness
right now but what i do know is that i
might not be able to put my final idea
into practice and i believe that you and
your organization may be able to help
your um
what what is it called scp foundation
and that changed everything researcher
alice immediately knew that this wasn't
a prank call a member of foundation
staff would never discuss foundation
matters even as a joke over an unsecured
line and a civilian would have no reason
to even know about the foundation was
she actually on the phone with the walt
disney it seemed odd and a little more
than unlikely on account of him being
dead for over 50 years if only
researcher ellis had checked her
clipboard a little closer then maybe she
would have realized that she was already
under the anomalous effects of
scp-2805 also humorously known as disney
on ice here's a fun question for you
what's your favorite disney movie
probably not what you expected to hear
from your friends at scp explained but
seriously we want to know tell us down
in the comments maybe you're a classical
purist and you consider snow white
cinderella or sleeping beauty to be the
best maybe you're a fan of the disney
renaissance and it's the little mermaid
beauty and the beast or the lion king
that are the true masterpieces or
perhaps you're a fan of their more
modern outings like tangled frozen and
moana or even their acquisitions like
marvel movies or the star wars series
personally i'm partial to tron legacy we
could go on but honestly we'd be here
all day the walt disney company started
by walter elias disney and his brother
roy back in 1923 has become one of the
most powerful and influential
entertainment companies in existence
their corporate machine is so huge and
sprawling it rivals the size and scope
of the scp foundation itself at its
influence the way we look at everything
from mice to pirates to norse legends to
space battles some give the united
states president the title leader of the
free world but anyone in that position
would happily drop everything to take a
phone call from the ceo of the walt
disney company even today the company
may be a global superpower these days
but none of it would have been possible
without walt himself born in 1901 walt
started his legendary company at the
tender age of 22. who would have known
that he would leave such an indelible
mark on human culture during his 65
years of life but he's not just an
entrepreneur animator writer voice actor
and film producer he's also decades
after his death an anomaly currently in
the capable hands of the scp foundation
while his cryogenically frozen severed
head is anyway and simply looking at
that severed head is what puts such an
anomalous damper on researcher alice's
nice quiet evening confused don't worry
let's start this demented disney fairy
tale at the beginning by which we mean
the end of walt disney's life walt
disney accomplished more in his life
than many of us would be able to claim
in several lifetimes he'd built one of
the most enduring entertainment
companies of all time won countless
awards and made millions of dollars from
his creations including the disneyland
theme parks the man had essentially made
his own name synonymous with magic
childhood whimsy and dreams coming true
however rather than focusing on the past
walt wanted to keep his eyes on the
future his grand vision went far beyond
movies and theme parks he wanted to
shape the way humanity lived for
centuries to come and the name of this
vision epcot or the experimental
prototype community of tomorrow while
you may know epcot as a mere portion of
the theme park in the florida walt
disney resort walt himself actually
intended it to be so much more as the
full name suggests he dreamed of
creating a functional community of
tomorrow with over 20 000 residents in
his own words epcot will take its cue
from the new ideas and new technologies
that are now emerging from the creative
centers of american industry it will be
a community of tomorrow that will never
be completed but will always be
introducing and testing and
demonstrating new materials and new
systems and epcot will always be a
showcase to the world of the ingenuity
and imagination of american free
enterprise it was certainly a utopian
idea though fans of bioshock might find
their eye twitching with flashbacks to
andrew ryan's disastrous rapture however
disney's problem didn't lie in his plans
but in himself despite his achievements
and larger than life legacy he was still
a mortal man when walt tragically
contracted lung cancer he finally became
aware of the fact that he may not live
to see his beautiful epcot dream
completed and despite having all the
money and fame a man could possibly ask
for he was beginning to realize that his
fortune couldn't buy him a second of
extra time or could it
this question would soon be answered
when representatives of a mysterious
company known as the owner roy
collective approached walt the strange
thing though was that the entities that
comprised this elusive group of
interests contacted walt in his dreams
you see the owneroid collective are a
group of entities known as the honoroy
or dreamers who exist only in the dream
space but sometimes interact with our
world through anomalous sometimes
semi-organic creations they sell as
products in that sense they were the
original imagineers their creations
include
scp-2028 a few hundred snow globes that
allow the user to remove and store their
nightmares and negative feelings within
and
scp-1498 which are creatures made from
old-fashioned rotary phones trailing a
huge number of wires coiled and arranged
into sheep-like bodies by calling the
phone on the creature's face a person
can order a custom dreamscape from the
owner roy naturally as creatures who
depend on dreams to survive the owner
roy were big fans of walt disney a man
who built a career of encouraging
children to dream their little hearts
out in exchange for his contributions to
the dreamscape they'd cut him a deal
they'd give him a special kind of
oneroid technology that would allow his
consciousness to continue to exist and
interact with the physical realm after
his death all they need to keep was his
head it was certainly a strange deal but
walt was thinking of his children his
grandchildren and their children and
grandchildren if he died now then his
tomorrowland dreams would die with him
he'd simply be known for some charming
animated films and a couple of amusing
theme parks not for truly changing the
future it seemed that the deal with the
unroi collective was too good to resist
the deal was struck and arrangements
were made to preserve disney's head and
consciousness after his death 10 days
after his 65th birthday on december 15
1966 walt disney passed away but that
was only the beginning of his new
anomalous life while the public mourned
disney's head was secretly removed and
preserved in a jar with anomalous
cryonics technology the device is also
fixed to a pair of rotary phones a
trademark of the honoroy and an
inscription that reads siberian
solutions from the owner roy collective
the anomalous effect was simple anyone
who looked directly at disney's frozen
head would receive a phone call in the
next 24 hours this phone call would be
from walt disney himself presumably
inhabiting the owneroid dreamscape now
with this handy trick he'd be able to
maintain his communications with the
rest of the walt disney company in
secret and see the creation of his
precious epcot project to its completion
but unfortunately that's not actually
how it happened following walt's death
his brother roy took over all walt
disney company operations while the
profitability of the company didn't
suffer under roy's control walt's final
dream did epcot mutated from the
sustainable functional community of the
future that walt desired into a mere
theme park the disney fied world's fair
that all orlando disney park visitors of
today would recognize as it turned out
most people in the disney company
weren't actually eager to take orders
from the former ceos severed had as a
result he became kind of a dark company
secret hidden away within the disney
parks after a number of reports of calls
from walt disney after the
entrepreneur's death the foundation
finally started to take notice they
conducted a thorough investigation of
the various disney bases of operation
and eventually found disney's frozen
head soon redesignated
scp-2805 in a secret compartment in the
legendary pirates of the caribbean ride
he was relocated to site-77 soon after
for further testing where his anomalous
abilities were later discovered sadly
for
scp-2805 while his calls to foundation
staff have all consisted of attempts in
enlisting the foundation's help in
making his epcot dreams a reality nobody
has yet taken him up on the offer since
his containment the foundation's main
priority has just been suppressing
conspiracy theories about the existence
of walt disney's cryogenically frozen
head a task which they undertake with
collaboration from the disney company in
order to muddy the waters in 1981 they
began productions of walt disney's world
on ice later known as disney on ice a
traveling ice skating show since then
they also released the incredibly
successful film frozen and its sequel to
corrupt any searches for key phrases
like disney's frozen or walt ice it's
been an incredibly effective smoke
screen as you can probably expect from
the scp foundation and sadly for walt
and fans of a mid-century perspective on
the future it's likely that walt
disney's dreams will stay within his
disembodied head so if you're hoping to
prove the existence of this truly wild
anomaly or somehow get in contact with
walt and help him bring epcot to its
intended glory you should probably just
let it go
now go check out scp-343 god and a sea
snail's fantasy
scp-1867 a gentleman for more scps you
can have a truly stimulating
conversation with